er ist ein querdenker und das weil er
die gesamte logik der fest fashion
industrie infrage stellt schneller
mehr billiger ist es wenn diestelow
nicht ansporn für sein handeln
in erster linie ist die mir ganz wichtig
dass man ausgebeutet wird das ist schon
mal wichtig und zum anderen ist
natürlich der umweltaspekt dass die
umwelt geschont wird wir haben ja nur
die eine welt noch um sein ehrgeiziges
ziel zu erreichen geht er weiter als
viele andere
es gibt ganz viele nachhaltige fashion
brands aber bei den meisten ist der
unterschied dass wir jetzt wirklich
innerhalb europa versuchen vom rohstoff
bis zum fertigen shirt alles zu regional
und hier meine ich die eu ganz einfach
mit zusammenzuhalten fashion made in
europe
der europäische binnenmarkt macht das
leicht oder das will ich überprüfen
kaufe mir mein shirt 100 prozent made in
europe und folge der produktionskette
der erste weg ist kurz nur ein paar
kilometer entfernt befinden sich die
büroräume und das lager hier wird der
vertrieb für den online-shop organisiert
neue kollektionen entworfen
und schablonen gefertigt mit den
t-shirts bedruckt werden
und auch für mein shirt ist das die
letzte station bevor es ausgeliefert
wird
[Musik]
von hier mache ich mich mit sven
diestelow auf dem weg nach polen in lodz
betreibt er seine eigene schneiderei mit
zehn mitarbeitern und will so seine
eigenen maßstäbe setzen
muss man wirklich ein kleidungsstück
20.000 kilometer um die welt schiffen
natürlich jetzt eine ferne osten
produktion viel günstiger als das was
ich hier betreibe aber da kann ich ja
auch gar nichts beeinflussen
mit den produktionsmengen der
textilindustrie die außerhalb der eu
produziert werden kann er nicht
mithalten
an seinem standort hält er aber fest wir
speziell im umkreis von lodz gibt es
eine komplette infrastruktur für die
textilherstellung textil besteht ja
nicht nur aus stoff oder aus dem mégane
sondern manchmal auch knöpfe man braucht
färbereien wenn man braucht strecke rain
man braucht viele viele dinge mehr wie
zum beispiel auch mal ein reißverschluss
oder ähnliches und all das gibt es hier
auch mein t shirt entsteht hier wird aus
dem gefärbten stoff zurechtgeschnitten
zusammengenäht und zu guter letzt für
den versand fertig gemacht
in der strickerei ums eck entsteht
ausgaben der stoff aus dem dann mein t
shirt wird
und das geht in die ansässige färberei
die nähe zur schneiderei soll kurze
transportwege garantieren und das
unternehmen muss sich bei der produktion
in polen an europäische umwelt standards
halten
der weg entlang der produktionskette
meines shirts führt mich weiter nach
griechenland
von dort kommt nämlich die baumwolle
zwar macht der baumwollanbau des landes
80 prozent der gesamten
baumwollproduktion der eu aber nicht
einmal ein prozent der weltweiten
baumwollproduktion aus der größte teil
der baumwolle wird also von weither
importiert das familienunternehmen war
war es macht das anders
die griechische garn spinnerei nutzt die
baumwolle von bauern aus dem umland und
das hat seinen preis
mein t shirt kostet ungefähr 20 euro
weit mehr als ein vergleichbares shirt
der fashion industrie und qualität hat
auch ihren wert und wenn wir es nicht
bezahlen möchten als europäischer bürger
dann muss dass jemand in asien bezahlen
bezahlen in form von harter arbeit eine
folge des fast fashion trends schneller
und mehr produzieren damit wir weniger
bezahlen
ein trend der auch den griechischen
familien unternehmen zu schaffen macht
ist in den letzten jahren hat mit den
hohen produktionskosten zu tun und mit
dem asiatischen wettbewerb der zu sehr
günstigen preisen anbietet wir arbeiten
gerade daran und das ist unser gedanke
so die gesamte kette in europa zu halten
und auch transparent zu sein
transparenz ist ein guter weg neues
bewusstsein zu schaffen
doch das wird bestimmt nicht einfach
letztendlich liegt es an den käufern die
konsumverhalten zu überdenken
mein neues t-shirt aber beweist dass es
funktionieren kann
fair fashion made in europe